[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
thank you so much how's everybody
feeling today you feeling good fantastic
whatever with everybody mind singing
with me for just one second could you
sing something
using a D no please if you could sing
[Music]
whoa
Wow
[Music]
see
thank you so much beautiful thank you
thank you so so do you feel that motion
do you feel yourself as part of that
motion things moving underneath the
surface so the language of musical
harmony is an absolutely extraordinary
one it's a way of navigating one's
emotional frameworks but without the
need to put things into words and I
think that as with many other languages
it doesn't matter how much you know
about a languages it does matter how
many words you can say how many phrases
you know what matters is the emotional
choices you make with this language so I
encourage us to embrace this idea as a
community which is the thing which in
time may grow us towards as opposed to
away from our own humanity thank you so
much
[Applause]
[Music]
we were
you know that my law
[Music]
in my heart
salty like the car the food
534 home in my heart
[Music]
don't
like I've never loved before in place
that are
[Music]
in the high
fill me afresh here aha
[Music]
thank you so much thank you
you
Oh
okay Jacob
okay we have some questions okay that
was spectacular Thank You Billy thank
you
those visualizations we just saw those
were happening in real time yeah yeah so
everything everything visual takes cues
from things which are ordeal or
something about a word and so everything
is real-time i IQ the loops I play the
instruments and then the tree for
example that you saw grow grows in such
a way that it takes slow long notes and
grows thick long branches and then it
tooks high quiets whatever and then it
grows thin small branches and then my
singing voice sort of blows wind against
the tree so you're 22 years old yes
indeed you played all of that by
yourself how did you get started and how
did this all evolve I have this magical
room in my house in North London you're
just like over there
thank you representing off London thank
you and this room I mean if this is my
family home I grew up in this in this
room filled with musical instruments but
most importantly I had a family who
encouraged me to invest in my own
imagination and so things I created
things I built were good things to be
building just because I was making them
I think that's such an important idea
but this room was my paradise
essentially and when I came to tour my
album which is called in my room I
thought I'd try and tour the room on the
road and that's quite a strange idea but
it's something that I've been working
for a couple years on making this come
to life Innes it's quite exciting to be
inside the circle so this is really like
to set up in your room here it kind of
is is it's similar to the room in the
sense that I can generate things on the
spot and I could be spontaneous which i
think is what both music and all of the
best ideas are all about you know so you
um won two Grammys for a record that you
made in your room by yourself and how is
that even possible I mean you know we
couldn't have done that that couldn't
have happened five years ago even right
no it's a brand new world the power is
now in the hands of the creator as I'm
sure you guys would agree as opposed to
that sort of do the big record company
executive or the bee man or something
like that it's somebody with a good idea
I mean
I'm saying this to guys who know this
already but it's somebody with a good
idea who can sow that seed that's the
person who carries the torch into the
world and yeah I made this album
completely on my own and I didn't I
didn't wait for anybody to do it I
didn't wait for somebody to say hey Jake
you should make an album on your own I
just went ahead and made it and I didn't
mind what people thought and two Grammys
is a massive bonus you know
[Applause]